the first full trailer for Zack Snyder's
Justice League just dropped and it does
a great job teasing some incredible
action scenes
yep UK maybe leathers it's Jan here and
in this video I'm going to take a look
at some interesting details you might
have missed and connections to the wider
DC Cinematic Universe quick warning
obviously the speculation and potential
spoilers ahead for the Justice League
movie let's start with all the hints and
teasers in the trailer so the mother
boxes which as we know from the deleted
scene in Batman V Superman will be key
to the plot and the Justice League movie
the first mother box appears in a scene
with Silas stone scientists and STAR
Labs who appeared in the metahuman video
case file that Diana Prince
aka when the woman watched in Batman V
Superman in that short scene we saw a
mother box in STAR Labs to react with
the amputated body of Silas's son Victor
stone to create cyborgs back in the
Justice League trailer it looks like
that mother box is being activated again
and as it does so a para demon appears
just behind Silas and in another shot it
also looks like cyborg is carrying or
dragging a mother box beside him by the
way did you notice the football trophies
in this shot which link to the scene
later in the trailer of Silas his son
Vic playing in a football game and that
of course fits in with the comics where
Vic stone was a top football player
later in the trailer the scene of the
pocalypse Ian's army fighting the Amazon
army and this could be part of the
movies opening sequence to establish the
history of dark sides attempts to invade
the earth and set up the reasons why you
sent Stefan wolf to search for the
mother boxes the previous comic-con
trailer showed a mother box being buried
and we know that the Amazons were given
one of the other boxes with the third
going to the Atlanteans to the third
mother box as a possible hint to its
location in this underwater shot of
mirror by the way in the comics mirror
is the queen of Atlantis and Aquaman's
wife speaking of Aquaman he gets to do
some very cool stuff in the new trailer
including riding on the outside of the
Batmobile and splitting the ocean with
his Trident and I also enjoyed the scene
of Bruce Wayne journeying to the fishing
village where we see Aquaman these very
cinematic shots of a snowy wilderness
unlikely footage from the production
shoot in Iceland the scene with Bruce
Wayne meeting Barry Allen already
appeared in the Comic Con footage
released by Warner Brothers but the next
shot is a very cool look at the flash
traveling through the Speed Force notice
incredibly powerful streaks not only
moving around him
also on his suit and according to set
visits the flashes suit is wrapped in
wires in order to contain the
electricity he generates when he's
feeding later in the trailer we also see
a brief glimpse of Barry's father dr.
Henry Allen played by Billy Crudup in
the comics and also the TV show Henry
Allen is imprisoned when he's wrongly
convicted to the murder of Barry's
mother now the shot that you see here is
the tunnel that was intended to connect
Gotham to Metropolis but was abandoned
in the 1930s set visits have also
revealed that this will be part of a key
action scene with Batman the flash and
Wonder Woman battling a horde of
parademons the vehicle they're using is
also new for Justice League and it's
called the night crawler
it's an all-terrain vehicle that can
move through all kinds of rough and
difficult environments and if you look
carefully you'll see it forming itself
into a kind of spider tank and in the
next shot it's even climbing vertically
right up the walls of this ventilation
shaft we also get to see the new
Batmobile in action and it's been
updated since Batman V Superman with the
addition of new guns on the front and
sides plus a cannon on top and it
wouldn't be a superhero movie or trailer
without a superhero landing right but
what I liked about this shot as well
with the visual similarities with Wonder
Woman heading up a trio of superheroes
just like she did in Batman V Superman
some funds might be disappointed there
was no Superman in this trailer but we
do get a shot of lois lane as she turns
around to look up at something
off-camera which makes me wonder whether
that something will be the Man of Steel
making his return so what did you think
of the Justice League trailer did it get
you hyped for the movie and were there
any Easter eggs or other things you
noticed let me know in the comments
below and if you enjoyed this I really
appreciate you hitting that like button
and why not subscribe for more of my
easter egg and comic book movie videos
check out some more videos you might
like right here thanks for watching and
see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers